[Music]
it's been you know every day every week
it was up a dollar or two a barrel so
it's been a steady increase for the last
uh year and three or four months
yesterday i paid five dollars and
fifteen cents a gallon for fuel at the
end of the day when i go to the grocery
store i'm a consumer just like everybody
else is so i'm i'm feeling it in the
pocketbook again
he's a trucker american drivers feeling
the squeeze as gas prices are hitting an
all-time high president biden claiming
that there is not much that he can do as
mitch leaders are reportedly ignoring
his calls to discuss oil joining us now
is america's newsroom co-anchor and the
five co-host dana parina hey dana hi
good to see you good to see you too the
president is saying he can't do anything
about it there's not much he can do
about it but he can
well there there's it also ignores
something that says that you your
administration and your party have had a
philosophy of figuring out a way to
depress fossil fuel and
exploration
and production in favor of greener
technologies that was a campaign choice
do you remember during the campaign he
said he wanted to end fossil fuels yes
and it caused a huge outro
uproar and everyone said
mr biden you can't say that on his side
you can't say it out loud is what they
meant but then if you look at the
policies like they were some very
concerted efforts to figure out a way to
basically depress
fossil fuel exploration and production
and figure out a way to get to this
greener energy future i think all of us
would love a greener energy future the
thing is we cannot change the law laws
of physics they are what they are and
the president is right in that he's
saying there's not much he can do right
away like right now this moment in order
to deal with the pain there's an
interesting idea that i saw that would
be something in terms of means tested
for people of a certain income level
that you could figure out a way to
provide some sort of voucher to help
them as you get through and you make it
temporary maybe a six month period as
other
domestic oil and gas hopefully get off
the ground
but when they say at the administration
that there's not much they can do
there's something they could do as they
move forward
they're just not willing to do that yet
well you've had the unique opportunity
to work in a white house what do you
think is happening behind closed doors
there when you've got the alaska
governor saying let our people drill
when you have democrats down in texas
saying we have so much oil here we would
rather be independent i think that there
in the administration within the white
house itself there might be some
dissenting voices but remember it was
even on november 3rd that the energy
secretary said
that
the pain of paying more at the pump was
what we had to go through in order to
get to this greener energy future just
this week kamala harris and pete buda
judge told everybody that the solution
to this is to go out and buy an electric
vehicle for sixty thousand dollars
the the what this opportunity that we
have right now in front of us is to be
more sober minded for a long
energy secure future which gets us to a
greener energy future in the long run if
i were them at the white house right now
i would say what all can we do to do
operation warp speed for domestic oil
and gas production that's what they
should be doing right don't you remember
when you bought your first car i mean we
i could barely afford i had to make so
many payments to afford my first like
used honda and i think it cost like
eighteen thousand dollars a sixty
thousand dollar car the average american
can't afford that
but i had the turismo i'll never forget
it and um i i got the card one of the
reasons my parents helped me get a car
was because i needed to take my sister
to her allergy shots right and that was
important like families are trying to
figure it out imagine you have three or
four cars in a family you're going to go
out and get three electric vehicles and
what do you remember in virginia when
they had that horrible snow storm and
all those people were stranded for 36
hours do you know what happened to the
people who had electric cars
they ran out of electricity on the road
and i'm not saying that electric
vehicles aren't a good solution for some
people sometimes but it's it's not
an immediate solution and when kamala
harris and pete buddha judge say that
they need to spend less time on twitter
and more time with like being more
serious about what we're going to do not
just in the short term but i really
think the long term for both energy
security price stability but our own
national security as well all right
what's coming up on america's newsroom
well we'll have rick perry the former
energy secretary for
president trump and he's also in texas
when president biden was there yesterday
he didn't meet with anybody in the oil
and gas industry i can't understand it
we also have ted cruz of course you know
him from texas as well and then michael
allen i love following him he's really
really smart and plugged in on
all things foreign policy so he'll be
there to kick us off today talking about
ukraine yeah all right thanks so much
thank you